Hi, and welcome to lesson four. Conference central is
starting to look like an interesting application. In addition to
user management that we introduced in lesson two, we
also added data store in lesson three. Now it's time
to look at data relationships and how to retrieve
data and make no mistake about it. There's a lot
of moving parts with respect to this. So you
better keep your eye on the ball. [SOUND] In addition
to data relationships and queries, we will be looking at datastore
consistency rules and transactions in this lesson. Now is probably a good time
to seriously start to checkout the documentation on the internet as well
to become a master of building
scalable applications. Let's get started, shall we?